on sait en tout cas qui a crevé merci
jean michel mr merci vous avez fait quoi
hier j'ai bossé là dessus parce que
marion non non vous êtes avec une peau
non j'ai bossé l'actuel une petite
fiancée en ce moment aux ja oui ça
quelque chose là je voulais sentir
comment s'appelle-t-elle marion non
série marion stéphanie vous l'avez connu
e je les ai connus je la connaissais
depuis longtemps non et alors est
comment ça c'est fait c'est le
confinement qui vous a rapproché tel
confinement oui effectivement une
histoire un peu plus compliqué mais
c'est vrai que côté nous on n'a que ça à
faire on n'a pas encore les bois tôle
axa a fait baver très bref voilà les
gens sont là il s'est étendu son fils je
sais bien sienne voilà allez on y va
demain demain c'est la réouverture des
bars des restaurants et ados c'est
aujourd'hui qu'il faut le dire que
visiblement cyril s'est passé de la
fredzone à la laugh zone exactement
baisse de 7 merci à on l'a on a docks de
doc et difool
j'en ai pris alors franchement les
jeunes juristes bottes non c'est juste
que il a pris il a pris le pot
d'échappement tout simplement alors oui
on a on est en amour en commun c'est les
chiens et l'admission calais de chiens
et comme elle était confinée deux chiens
dans un petit appartement
mlt panouillot téléphone très compliqué
et c est joli bas vient chez moi j'ai
une terrasse j'ai la chance d'avoir une
terrasse je vois là et je suis dit voilà
comme ça les chiens au moins pourront
s'arrêter à ça sera moins compliqué
pourtant etc et du cou et m'a dit je ne
voulais pas abuser j'y vais dans
quelques jours et de deux jours trois
jours quatre jours et il ya là est resté
deux mois mais ça s'est fait tout entre
nous avec les chiens entre nous les
chiens soient moins les chiens votre
chat et son chien et son chien et un de
ses chiens y ta journée
le confinement et maintient la croquette
ça s'est fait progressivement c'est pas
se passer de jean jeux tels tapoter le
genou très bien voilà et puis après
précis mans s'est passé du bisou hausse
assez rapprochées et puis après c'était
la galoche puis après la spirale du don
fehr
[Rires]
ma fiche de moi qu'on aille au bout
d'une heure je pense moi la personne ne
pense que c'est bon de dire des choses
merci kelly est avec nous commençons à
kelly ça va super vous avez fait quoi
hier j'étais à la campagne avec des amis
huawei on a kiffé tout entre path
c'était très cool tu vas y avait des
chiens y avait mon chien sait tous que
c'était le seul chien non y avait des
enfants sinon parce qu'il reste un chien
célibataire la maison